y en directo a Vamos hasta Caracas con
nuestra corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
hoy el gobierno del presidente Nicolás
Maduro volvió a negar que cometió
crímenes de lesa humanidad lo hizo a
través de un documento presentado a la
Corte Penal Internacional que Investiga
supuestas violaciones a los derechos
humanos en el país en el marco de las
protestas sociales de 2017 y también
criticó la gestión de esta institución
Daniela muy buenas noches Qué es lo que
dice este documento enviado por el
ejecutivo venezolano cuéntenos
en este documento y en el comunicado
emitido por la cancillería venezolana se
denuncian irregularidades y violaciones
al debido proceso por parte de la
Fiscalía de la Corte Penal Internacional
se le acusa de no ser Imparcial de tener
supuestos vínculos directos con
organizaciones no gubernamentales que
han aportado información en contra de
las autoridades venezolanas se dice
además que este proceso forma parte de
una estrategia para un cambio de
gobierno en Venezuela impulsado por
Estados Unidos y se le calificó de
falacias de agresión mediática y
geopolítica se presenta además en este
documento el supuesto testimonio de una
persona no se dan no se dan detalles
sobre de quién se trata pero que habría
dado un testimonio ante la fiscalía de
la Corte Penal Internacional de haber
sufrido violaciones a derechos humanos y
al ser consultado por autoridades
venezolanas supuestamente habría
desmentido que haya sido víctima
recordemos que este informe este
documento presentado por el estado
venezo lano responde a que este 28 de
febrero vencía el plazo para que
presentara sus alegatos del Por qué no
se quiere que se continúe con esta
investigación por parte de la Fiscalía
de la Corte Penal Internacional sobre
violaciones a derechos humanos cometidos
bajo la administración de Nicolás maduro
durante 2014 específicamente durante las
protestas antiguos reglamentales y
detenciones arbitrarias cometidas
durante el año 2017 a propósito Daniela
cómo avanza la investigación de la cpi
en Venezuela
recientemente la sección para la
participación de víctimas y reparaciones
precisó que entre el 13 de enero y el 14
de febrero de este año 441 individuos y
47 familias presentaron sus casos ante
el formulario emitido por este
departamento para recoger los casos de
violaciones a derechos humanos este
cierra el próximo siete de marzo el
próximo paso es que el 21 de Marzo se
deberá presentar el informe ante los
jueces de la sala de cuestiones
preliminares y hasta el 31 de marzo
tiene el fiscal Karen cam para presentar
sus alegatos si lo hubieron responder a
estas denuncias emitidas por el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro con respecto al
procedimiento que se lleva a cabo se
esperaría que a partir de abril se pueda
conocer la decisión de la sala de
cuestiones preliminares de la Corte
Penal Internacional esto sería un
importante paso para las denuncias que
han hecho tanto organizaciones no
gubernamentales como dirigentes
políticos y Víctimas de violaciones a
derechos humanos en contra de la
administración de Nicolás maduro que
aseguran que en Venezuela no han
encontrado respuestas y atenciones a sus
denuncias por parte del Estado
venezolano asegura que no es necesario
esta investigación y que los casos sean
atendido en Venezuela